[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
la France en Amérique du Sud renforcée
nos relations avec nos voisins
la plus grande collectivité territoriale
française est aussi celle qui représente
la France en Amérique du Sud il s'agit
de la Guyane avec ses 83000
km². la France partage avec ses voisins
immédiats que sont le Brésil et le
Suriname ou plus lointains comme le
Guyana les nombreux atouts de cette
région elle est également confrontée au
même problématiques telles que le
développement des activités illicites
les questions relatives à l'immigration
clandestine les défilés à la protection
de l'environnement est plus
particulièrement à la lutte contre la
déforestation parce que ces enjeux
régionaux appellent une réponse
coordonnée la mission d'information
lancée par la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées ces données deux objectifs
le premier est d'identifier les axes de
possibles renforcement de la relation
bilatérale entre la France et le Brésil
le second est d'analyser les atouts et
les défis que représentent la présence
de la France en Amérique du Sud tout en
mettant l'accent sur les relations
qu'elle entretient avec ses voisins dans
cette perspective Joël gariaume André
Vallini Catherine Dumas Philippe folio
et Nicole Duranton sont partis à la
rencontre de divers acteurs locaux avant
de tracer des recommandations adaptées à
chaque espace sud-américain appréhendé
dans le cadre de cette mission la
première escale fut le plus grand pays
au monde partageant une frontière
terrestre avec la France le Brésil
la récente élection du président Lula a
ouvert un nouveau chapitre de nos
relations diplomatiques
cette main tendue doit être saisie
rapidement alors que plusieurs de nos
alliés et compétiteurs ont déjà opéré un
rapprochement parfois plus marqué avec
ce nouveau Brésil la mission recommande
notamment de créer un conseil
franco-brésilien permettant un dialogue
bilatéral régulier sur les sujets
économiques et financiers ou encore de
renouveler le partenariat militaire et
stratégique de 2006 en l'étendant à de
nouveaux champs tels que le domaine
terrestre le cyber ou le spatial afin
d'intensifier la coopération
transfrontalière avec le Brésil la
mission propose de mettre en place des
patrouilles conjointe permettant aux
militaires des deux pays d'appréhender
les auteurs d'actes illicites sur le
territoire de l'autre pays
elle souhaite plus globalement conforter
la coopération judiciaire en matière
pénale au niveau de la coopération
culturelle la mission suggère d'ouvrir
une alliance Française à Macapa sur les
rives du fleuve Amazone par ailleurs les
rapporteurs entendent consolider la
coopération dans le domaine de la
protection de l'environnement à cet
effet ils invitent à étudier des
modalités de rapprochement entre le parc
national des montagnes du tumucumach au
Brésil et le Parc amazonien de Guyane
qui pourrait former la plus grande zone
mondiale de la biodiversité après s'être
rendu en Guyane française les
rapporteurs ont poursuivi leur
déplacement au Suriname et au Guyana
dans l'optique d'identifier les axes
possibles de renforcement des relations
de la France avec ces deux pays du
plateau d'aiguillages
la mission souligne la nécessité
d'accompagner le développement du
Suriname un pays en proie à une
situation économique et sociale
fortement dégradée depuis 2020 au cours
des entretiens les autorités Suriname
mais ont mis en avant l'insuffisance des
moyens des armées et des forces de
sécurité intérieure pour lutter
efficacement contre les activités
illicites la France pourrait leur
apporter un soutien logistique en
envisageant par exemple des sessions de
matériel qu'il s'agisse de véhicules de
moyens de communication ou encore
d'équipements individuels la mission
invite également à positionner la France
comme un partenaire clé du Guyana
en matière économique ce pays a
longtemps été le plus pauvre d'Amérique
du Sud mais la découverte en 2015
d'importants gisements de pétrole en mer
à grandement rebattu les cartes le
Guyana qui posséderait les deuxièmes
plus grandes réserves de pétrole par
habitant au monde offre désormais
d'importantes opportunités pour les
entreprises françaises le pays demeure
néanmoins confronté au défi de la
criminalité organisée la mission
préconise de renforcer la coopération
pour lutter contre la pêche et leur
paillage illégaux et contre les trafics
de stupéfiants en particulier de cocaïne
à destination de l'Amérique du Nord et
de l'Europe enfin sur le plan
diplomatique il conviendrait de créer
une ambassade de plein exercice à George
Town la capitale
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]